franklin pod's goals
i'm unbelievable
everything everything that steven
gerrard is meant to be better than the
lamppod at mm-hmm the stats tell you
that lamport is yeah stats tell you yeah
that's better so
that they don't but steve but steve
jordan is meant to be meant to be meant
to have a better ping meant to be a
better golf swing midfielder but he
isn't he's meant to be a bit more
creative midfielder but he isn't
[Music]
it's trouble
ah absolutely marvelous my name is
yourself good job
long time no see
i've been following you though i'm aware
i've been uh i've been here you know
i've been hearing a lot of fun lads you
know i'm your number one fan
jose mourinho's 2005 chelsea side was
better than klopp's title winning side
three
two one
i mean this is this is ridiculous this
is you're gonna have to reconsider
that's ridiculous that's ridiculous
that's stupid and you're the older
person so you should have them assured
i'm incredible
he's the best player in the world and
even though i do stand by that for video
purposes i will absolutely say right now
that the fact you've gone strongly again
is your job crops title winning team
isn't even klopp's best team
klopp's title winning team isn't even
his best team the team the team that
didn't win the league was a better team
for liverpool than the team
so now we can say two teams is better
than that team
no but the point the point is that
chelsea team was
absolutely sensational yeah
that finished with 97 points second but
chelsea nevertheless it's not even your
best if it's not even klopp's best team
yeah then it's then it's incomparable to
chelsea well tonight just means you've
got two better teams than you impossible
player for player player for player will
drop to do it
because i'm happy to go through it
chelsea had pretty much an international
captain per position
finish
we have a lot of captains in our team
i think that that that chelsea team
of that chelsea team of o5
were probably the best premier league
team that has ever existed
i do not understand how you can go with
the team that got more points than the
team that you're talking about to say
that that's how many players want to get
97 and 99
back-to-back two champions league finals
back-to-back and this is what i'm saying
to you like this wasn't just even though
we've never got one of you we never just
just the league but the league oh yeah
yeah
that team won the the league cup and the
league
well league and champions league is this
team but it didn't win the same season
not in the same season but i don't
really think like no but that means
chelsea chelsea retained
the better premier league so if you're
doing that chelsea retain this this
chelsea team that we're talking about
retain the premier league if you're
gonna go champions league look at the
team that we were competing against when
you look at the points that we actually
accumulate to finally actually win that
97 and 99 back to back
chelsea i've never ever got anything
close to them it was harder to win the
league you know we won the league
back-to-back yeah you won the league but
you never got them points tally is you
win it's dominance you never won the
league when it was in december we won
the league in december the reason how
many teams have won the league in
december the reason that children
everyone was writing themselves off let
alone just saying
part of the reason that chelsea didn't
hit that points tally wasn't because we
couldn't it's because also we'd won the
league you're also you're you your point
about manchester city saying that
liverpool's overcome the best seat i
think that you could actually say it's
harder to win the league in o5 than it
is now how because you had to overcome
two you had to overcome bengal and
fergie every team has got a good player
now the premier league is on a much
higher level than what it was back then
when you talk about the bottom ten sides
and the premier league in that era they
never had a star man like some of them
might only have to finish above man city
to win the league now yes then you have
to finish because they're so far ahead
of everyone else they're not they're not
mourinho united combined are they well
they got more points than man united
in their palms and under fifa's arsenal
team didn't even get as much as we did
in the second place but the arsenal team
that chelsea beat to the title was the
invincible team yeah so chelsea
you're saying that you've got about 18
years
you're saying that manchester city
liverpool has overcome man city and
therefore that's harder but chelsea had
to overcome the invincibles but you've
got to talk about the context of how
dominant man city have been i'm not
saying these two
invincibles it's easy to title a story
better than what it is it's easy to give
a a headline that's going to draw eyes
of course the invincibles but manchester
city we're talking about a team that got
100 points rory when you talk about
someone you can talk to said alex
overall outside the premier league pep
guardiola is your man and james club was
the one who overtook him and he was the
one who built this team with brilliance
and again he's done that with noto he's
doing that with a southampton center
back who was not and he's done it with a
right back that can't defend he's done
it with a chelsea flop he's done it with
manny who wouldn't even want to fight
him so you you agreed
ferguson is best
manager ever yeah this chelsea team had
to beat him to it so your point about
man city is actually notified by your
because you can't ignore longevity but
when you look at a shorter period of
time and what pep guardiola has achieved
you can argue he's been more dominant
the o5 team it had to overcome the
invincibles it had to overcome
manchester united it won more trophies
because it won the league cup as well
and it retained the league who would win
if you put them against each other and i
think our team was off
so when you're talking about the team
versus the team on the day i think
liverpool is better even if you want to
break down the 11 i think there's a lot
of players that you probably
underestimate that would get into that
11. i really really do i think that
winning more trophies counts because it
it retained the league it's a [ __ ]
the invincibles which is significant
overcome fergie i just think that i
think it's very difficult to say
that it isn't this chelsea team i think
we're going to have to agree to disagree
name of the shot name of the shot that's
why i did it
[Laughter]
frank lampard oh don't do this to me
here we go don't do this here we go was
the better player
than steven gerrard like this is where
we're going to need a bigger table sorry
for the three two one i apologize
wait wait
right so
let's do you want to start or do you
want me to start i'm happy either i'm
i'm happy
i've got to go i'll fall on my sword you
go for it all right i'm gonna go for the
fish so we're talking about the player
right we're talking about who's better
what's up so let's let's break down the
attributes who do you think was a better
defensive player
i think i think it was jedi and i don't
really know how to far better in a
tackle frankly far better in the title i
have positively i think steven jenner
got more stuck in defensively and i also
feel like he's defensively
better i think i think that that side
not to mention that the flank lampard
was in a better defensive team than
stephen jackson
still pulling that defensive policy in
franklin parties often overlooked
because he was such a good goal scoring
midfielder yeah the work rate and the
ability attacking
winning
being worse than steven gerrard isn't me
saying that he's a bad defender but i do
believe that he's not as skilled as
steve and jedi when it comes to reading
the game steven gerard
he was rash but he also won the ball a
lot of the time he gets stuck in and
then he fears the opposition and then he
don't come out and let him take a long
shot from whatever amount of yards
anyway shooting both great shooters but
yeah i do i'll probably concede that as
you say both great shooters but in terms
of the ping
and the value i put on the ping
character yeah
i mean you you were limited yeah yeah
steve and jeremy and all the way 2015
with his left foot
a complete pinger against everton in the
fa cup final like they've they've both
done it they've both done it but i'm
giving you this one in terms of the ping
yeah it's not about
how good frank lampard is it's just
gerald's probably got one of the best
pings i've ever seen in football so i'll
give you that the only argument that
frank lampard has compared to stephen
gerard is the trophies
goals assists goals
i often reign on stats because i think
that they're misleading but what i would
say is
frank lampard's goals
i'm unbelievable
everything everything that steven
gerrard is meant to be better than the
lab hard
the stats tell you that land points yeah
stats tell you yeah lampard is better so
that they don't but steve but steve
jordan is meant to be meant to be meant
to have a better ping meant to be a
better goalscoring midfielder but he
isn't he's meant to be a bit more
creative midfielder but he isn't can't
you can see that was maybe because he
was in the wayside
because comfortably over there careers
was in a considerably worse team than
frank lampard but i do not think you
will ever see one man carry such a team
as much to the lengths that stephen jedi
khan he does because we wouldn't know
premier league in that time but we
wouldn't have won a champions league
without stephen jenner who went he took
over an ac milan team and we're not just
talking any orders on any 1819 like
just scored
all around the field so
steven gerrard won us that game yep near
enough single-handedly yeah i mean frank
captain frank manpower captain chelsea
to european glory as well
it did happen do you agree with this are
we arguing over the best two premier
league midfielders ever yes absolutely
hundred percent i think it's kind of
comfortable but
jedhart's numero uno for me and the
reason why i will always persist with
that case
is istanbul and everything that he done
after that even towards the dead end of
his liverpool career i'd say we're still
our best midfielder so
i can never try
his career where he became chelsea's
best midfielder the amount of assistance
there's no need for that lordy do you
know what i mean
but i didn't like myself
i don't know i did that
i wouldn't have felt this bad song thank
you for showing remorse but but to
conclude they're both very similar in
teams of players for sure but i think
jedi is the better player and now even
though it's off topper i think he's the
much better manager so he's just much
better
jurgen klopp is better than any manager
chelsea have ever had three
two
one
yes
percent and 100
and i admire jose mourinho to the
maximum i even admire thomas two shall i
have my antonio conte who's done a job
at chelsea for sure and i'm sure there's
been many other great managers but jose
mourinho is the one that stands out to
me and i feel like they're the ones that
were probably competing in this instance
the senegalese manager came out the
other day and said it's it's mo salah
and it's sadio manny was brought up to
the title well sadio manny was at
southampton mo salah was at romer he was
a chelsea flop that was that that was
what he was labeled as vans like
75 million he was looked at as harry
maguire so when you think of the players
they have turned into arguably the best
in their position
i don't understand oh i don't see a
manager who's had that same effect for
players who were so low down in the
peckham order previously see i think
that what jose mourinho did is
comparable in terms of where chelsea
were because you've got to remember that
when jose mourinho came into chelsea
chelsea haven't won the league for 50
years of course
chelsea but the circumstances had
changed when jose mourinho came in yes
they changed before they changed before
mourinho got there yeah they didn't and
we didn't win the league so
what i mean is abramovich came in but he
was there early on in the ten year one
yeah he was very early but abramovich
came in uh ranieri was a manager we
didn't win the league yeah it took
mourinho to take us to the title he then
retained the title he then came back to
chelsea and won it again to win the
league when klopp did it
it was too yeah you had to you had to
finish above one team yeah
jose mourinho landed in this country and
had to upset two a two goliath football
two-horse arsenal two hundred and goals
and manchester united two huge teams
that i will not take any credit away but
manchester city you saw the points that
they accumulated name me a squad that's
probably better than premier league
history because nostalgia can be a very
beautiful thing but when you break down
the squad for breaking down and then
breaking down the backup squad that they
had i'm i i think jayden klopp had the
more difficult task to be able to go
ahead and win that league with the
resources that he was given because jose
mourinho even though he's competing with
arsenal he's still got them he's still
got the money himself he's still got the
back on himself welcome clock
it sounds it sounds so sneery from me
but your unclocked won one league what
do you think is the lack of
investments he won the champions league
time he won the champions league portal
but he also had great plays of portfolio
i'm not trying to take anyone away that
was still an amazing achievement but i
chelsea which is what we're talking
about
was brilliant as well but think about
the backhand that then teams are being
given look at the elevens that then
teams possessed and that was due to the
law i do not see jose mourinho of any
either taking over the liverpool team
that clocked it and going on to achieve
what he has i think as things stand
mourinho
won the league ended chelsea's 50-year
wait for a league retained it
left came back won the league again
as of today as of today
it has to be jose mourinho i have to
very very much disagree
i need another table because i want to
go further i want to go because i said
this last time
no i i genuinely believe that what jacob
klopp has achieved not only because you
but you brought up incident you brought
support yeah
won the frigging league against bayern
munich a team like since he's left i've
won the league near enough every season
so it goes to show that what jaden clock
was doing there and where dortmund had
been with a manager such as yours
currently and thomas tuchel who also
couldn't win any major with them so it's
a very difficult task to do they are
both brilliant managers
jurgen klopp may eclipse jose mourinho
but judging it today
nearly christmas time in december
2021
the answer is
the man the one the only the egg and
nobody club
chelsea selling mo seller is the biggest
transfer mistake premier league history
three
two one
you messed up oh you don't think it's a
mistake because it benefited you uh yeah
oh wait there if i got a goal would
agree to say that it was a mistake i
think i think you're saying you disagree
because oh sorry yeah i strongly agree
as well i strongly agree that's what i
meant to say okay
the biggest so think about from the ones
but in this instance rory we're talking
about on form the best player in the
world a player five seasons in a row
with 20 plus goals by the way we are in
december this is a joke of a player this
is someone who hasn't paid for a goal
and whether you
whether you know what you can think
about the player that he was at you but
you just didn't give them enough chance
and then you've even got other examples
within your team you've got the cafe you
let go and brought back you got to bring
but i think saleh in terms of the order
that he brings in terms of the audience
that he brings number one muslim athlete
in the world and with the numbers that
he brings as well as overall
performances i can't see how any one of
those other players that i've just
listed like de bruyne and stuff like
that can be compared to that mistake and
how much did you let him go for you are
right you are you are right to a degree
but you've got to remember that the
player that we sold yes isn't the player
that you're talking about at all of
course it isn't the player that you're
talking about and the other because you
couldn't notice it but you could be just
the brilliance it's very difficult to
call it a mistake when chelsea won a
league
insult somebody won a league you never
won the league every year after that no
no but but when we made that decision to
let salah go we won as a kid so you
can't expect them to win you the league
title you could have won more league
titles with a mo salad in your side if
you developed them but what you're
suggesting is that people should
effectively have be able to turn into
mystic meg nobody would have been able
to nobody would have been able to to
foresee mohamed salah deserving about it
not not then though what happened
no because with the form changed didn't
it the form changed
the ends unfairly but he became a better
player is it a mistake to make a
decision based upon the information that
you've got at the time
if that information changes later in the
day like you can't you can't predict
that like you know what you know when
you're obviously had something before to
become the player that he is now you
don't just be you've
already
you know when you got rid of jay
spearing if jay spearing had gone on to
become
but say jay spearing had gone on to
become like one of the best footballers
in the world yeah you watched him right
you've done the eye test on him you've
seen him play football he's not good
enough to play for my team if he then
becomes a different person if hans or
butch he never
no but but you can't foresee that it's
impossible isn't it how is it impossible
when salah has became the best player in
the world hindsight is a beautiful thing
for sure but how have you not noticed it
in attributes of certain qualities to
what has now become one of the most
lethal finishes that this league's ever
seen because i don't think he was the
same player i don't think he was the
same person he has redefined himself
he's become
he has become in my opinion now worthy
of a ballon d'or he has become the best
footballer in the world is it the
biggest
regret how is it weirder the biggest one
the biggest transfer mistake in premier
league is trans famously you've missed
out on one of the greatest wingers to
ever grace the league and he was at your
disposal
so
yes yeah you're very good at it
you're very good i tell them
no you're right because somebody at
somebody at stanford bridge needs to be
watching this these players and even if
it's not working even if you as you as
you put it even if he does have a
terrible game away in a particular in a
particular cup tie somebody needs to go
hang on a minute he's just scored
against arsenal there's six nil
let's let's persevere he's gonna be
fantastic you're absolutely right it's a
shocker chelsea made her chelsea made a
mistake hugely and you've gave what's
lead title thank you very much yeah
double it
john terry was a better defender than
virgil van dijk is dummy three two
one
but yeah i mean this is just obvious
i'll talk about peak of both
like all we talk about overall the fact
that you have to clarify means that you
know be look be true to yourself be the
man don't you want to be here i don't
know
i don't want i'm the only client i don't
want to do this
be the man that you want to be john said
he is so bossy james james
why didn't he just join us when he was
you're a man of honor i'm doing that i'm
not even going fully over the land let
me have this but this is what i am going
to say because i don't want to just feel
like i'm going down oh dear you do this
to me like baba this is a joke right so
virgil van dyke at his peak when you're
talking about peak season i don't think
john said he ever had a season as good
as page that's just me but over
longevity with all due respect when
john's head john said he was winning
friggin leagues when at the same stage
the virgil was in celta yeah in terms of
being a captain i don't think i think
only him and roy keane have capped into
club to a more premier league he's
fought for each so he's captain chelsea
to all those trophies virgil van dyke
virgil vanzai turns up late to the party
and when you do that
it you know even salah right now who on
form is the best player in the world but
you can't put them in there with ronaldo
messi because they've been doing what
he's doing
every single season of their career so
it's incompatible but that's why i i've
tried to cheat my way into it and be
like what about the peak because it's a
peak then you're having a conversation
and i do think van zak will do this
until he's about 35 i believe he's got
the potential day what virgil van dijk
is so good at you don't really lose he
might get a little bit slow but he's
still so good at covering his garage and
stuff that i do think he will be in the
conversation with one of the greatest
who ever grades this league with the rio
ferdinand's with the john teddies
but
in this case it's just time it's gone
against them a little you're a good man
james you're good man i didn't
anticipate this i mean i knew you're a
good man but i didn't anticipate you're
being being sold i mean just remember
it's it's still on the line a little bit
no great i rate it
so would i want harry kane in my team 99
of the people watching ain't me they're
not west ham fans they're not watched
antonio go from a right back to the best
striker in the league great story you
know what i mean so but
it's not that changed effect right now
because this is when the question is i'm
having antonio